He hoped you would decide
to present myself to the propers of action
Car wash,
yes.
Puigdemont
thus announced his candidacy for the Catalan elections.
Very studied scenography,
him on stage,
only accompanied by the lady,
the European flag and 3 words,
President Carles Puigdemont,
nothing more
1 time confirmed what everyone expected
to be presented,
who wants to be a New President,
solved another unknown,
will only set foot in Spain again,
will only risk arrest
if he can be invested at the head of the generality.
Today.
Let's start with so real the day
that sanctity is not with me,
if it is for the servei of the country.
If SOS is running for president,
She already says most of them
he parliamentarian that Han proposes
to run for the nomination.
I would definitely like to go into exile
that day to attend for his 9th predoperliament
and demand the confidence of the camera